how is it possible that modern medicine
recommends certain treatments that are
flat out wrong well that's what I asked
Dr Paul offit the director of vaccine
education center at Children's Hospital
Philadelphia and member of the FDA
vaccine advisory committee yeah he
advises the FDA on what vaccines to
approve he's not just an advisor though
but a vaccine Creator having developed a
rotavirus vaccine which is estimated to
save hundreds of lives per day around
the world Dr offit is also the author of
one of my favorite books Overkill when
modern medicine goes too far which
directly challenges 15 modern medical
practices some of which you may have
experienced yourself huge thanks to
Audible for sponsoring this video
to start off Dr offit and I discuss how
important it is to be skeptical even
with modern or revolutionary medicine
for example he attacks the established
practice of lowering every fever and the
overuse of antibiotics so I asked him
what's one to do like for me as a young
Family Medicine physician like let's
take the antibiotics discussion on its
own you're a proponent for decreasing
lengths of antibiotic courses when
appropriate decreasing the use of
antibiotics when not appropriate
it's easier said than done what than
what is available in clinical practice
patients come in with a certain
understanding that takes a lot of time
to debunk time that we oftentimes don't
have with the patients A lot of times
they come in with sort of expectations
that they should get the antibiotic and
if they don't they will leave you a
negative review or negative score on
your after visit summaries and these are
things that active clinicians have to
think about in addition to the science
and in addition to the worry about what
could potentially go wrong with this
patient what's your recommendation to
Young doctors around the world well it
first of all and I would extend it to
the hospital I mean I I don't see
outpatients but I see inpatients in our
hospital and the Physicians that are
taking care of these patients want
antibiotics they want them for a long
period of time so the pressure doesn't
come from parents or from patients it
also comes from doctors
what my my advice is is you know we're
entering a post-antabiotic era I mean we
have children in our Hospital especially
some with say cystic fibrosis that are
affected with bacteria that are
resistant to all commercially available
antibiotics I mean we're starting to use
bacteriophage therapy meaning viruses
that kill bacteria I don't know if you
ever read Sinclair Lewis's Aerosmith but
I mean that was that that was the
subject of that book written in the
early 1920s before we had antibiotics I
mean we used to use bacteriophages a
hundred years ago it's a little
frightening that we're going back to
that at some level so that's what's at
stake and so for me the attitude is is I
certainly understand where the parents
are coming from or in the case of the
hospital where the doctor is coming from
but we have a judicious use of
antibiotics program in our hospital and
and and we push back and I think you you
know you have to do the same thing
knowing that you will pay a certain
price for that but the price you know
eyes on the prize and the prize is the
child the prizes you want to make sure
sure that you're not generating you know
more and more resistant bacteria which
will only be more and more difficult to
treat in that child so although the
parent may want it it may give you a bad
review do the right thing but yes you
know doing the right thing isn't always
doing the easy thing the concept of
medical inertia you mentioned earlier I
think is so well stated in the book I'd
love for you to briefly touch on that
you know we do things a certain way and
when you try and I know because I've
given talks relating to things in this
book and what you'll often hear is
pushback from Physicians is look I mean
I've been doing it this way for 20 years
and it works well but but see you don't
know that if you don't do it that way
that would also work right so that's
what you're up against you're up at this
sort of you know anecdotal
um I've done this and it's worked and
you know it's like this is my experience
but you know doing something wrong a
thousand times doesn't constitute
experience and also remember in a boxer
not big money makers for these
pharmaceutical companies because there's
something you give just a few times say
at most during the year you're not
taking it every day they're never going
to be with lipid lowering agents or
neurological drugs or diabetes drugs so
they're not not a priority for these
companies and
um we're there we've taken our first
steps into the post-antibiotic era and
I'm working in a hospital I certainly
see that we've used bacteriophages in
our Hospital on children with cystic
fibrosis who are infected with something
that for which we have no antibiotics
because we have pushed and pushed and
pushed as bacteria into complete
resistance the bacteria ultimately will
win out they they will win out and
unless we're careful about Howard how
we're handling all this yeah antibiotics
stewardship is really important and much
in the same vein one of the obstacles I
run into quite often is with
fever-reducing agents frequently even
amongst friends and family when they
call me for advice uh when I tell them
to not use fever lowering agents when
they have a very mild fever uh there's
shock on their face because that is not
something that is generally talked about
and I don't understand why it's not
taught in medical schools it's not
discussed amongst my colleagues I've
never had a lecture on it despite
attending thousands of lectures and yet
there's so much evidence that you you
stated in this book about allowing a
fever to help inflammatory cytokines to
help your immune system function better
to potentially decrease autoimmune
conditions in the future why do we
continue to use fevery lowering agents
and what can we do about it well we
continue to use them because that makes
us feel better
um it's a short-lived game
um but you're you're exactly right I
mean you put your finger on it why don't
we learn about this I mean I really
learned about it the most when I read
about it for the purpose of writing the
book there are probably 20 studies
showing that for people who have let's
say bacterial pneumonia that are treated
with with antibiotics that they will
have either more severe disease or long
or lasting disease and that's true over
and over again and in the world of
vaccines which is my world if you give
antibiotics you know prior to getting a
vaccine you lower the immune response
because why do we make fever well it's
not to keep pharmaceutical companies in
business we make fever because our
immune system works better at a higher
temperature across the board B cells
make antibodies that are more
efficiently and at higher higher
affinity and higher Tire T cells help B
cells do it cytotoxic t cells help kill
viral infected cells that but but we pay
a price for fever you pay a metabolic
price for fever and it's uncomfortable
having fever which is why we only have
fever when we need it and and so why
blunt this critical aspect of your
immune response the one story I tell in
the book because it was so striking was
a 15 year old boy who was playing soccer
he's hit in the hip with a soccer ball
he develops a thrombus a clot in his in
the a vein at his hip which becomes
infected with the bacteria uh uh
stapharias which is resistant right so
MRSA methyl and resistance therefore so
we're treating with the right antibiotic
Vancomycin day after day though he
continued to have bacteria in his
bloodstream because they had this septic
thrombophlebitis day after day after day
continued to have high fever and was
treated Round the Clock with anti-fever
medicines and and you know after a while
I thought you know why blunt this this
critical aspect of the immune response
so is that down with a boy who was Brave
I sat down with his parents who were you
know perfectly going to to listen to
what we had to say and most importantly
sat down with the nurses because this is
like one of the the pillars on which
nursing stands is thermoregulation so we
all got in a room we had this discussion
and we stopped reading his fever and
within two days he is his blood culture
cleared we finally cleared it now that
may have that's just an end of one it
may have been coincidence but not as far
as the parents were concerned or the
nurses they thought we were Geniuses
because you know we just didn't agree
with antipyretics yeah I think
electronic medical records definitely
plays a role here because it was so
often that automatically when you were
treating an infectious disease patient
the order is almost automatically went
in that if for fever above 101 uh give
Tylenol it was like one of the order
sets that auto populated and I never
understood why that was the case I even
intuitively coming out as a resident
felt like that was wrong and I never
understood the logic obviously if we
have a patient who's weak who's not
resting who has cardiovascular risk Etc
there might be indications for it but
the whole majority of the population I
never understood even I'm going to throw
my father under the bus he's a physician
who is trained in the USSR as a
physician came to the United States went
to medical school here again so that's
two times medical school and yet when I
was younger the second my temperature
went up you have to take aspirin you
have to take motion something and I
would argue with him why am I taking
this like it didn't make sense to me and
to this day he still believes treating a
fever is the right thing because of I
think the concept that you uh so well
illuminate which is medical inertia it
worked for him for so long keep doing it
why change what works back to the
interview in just a second but first I
want to thank Audible for sponsoring
this video I actually found Dr offit's
book Overkill when modern medicine goes
too far on Audible and listening to it
was so interesting I had to have him on
the channel to discuss it more I
listened to audible every time I'm on
the go in the gym going to the hospital
even walking bare I love it because it
allows me to multitask so I listen to
what I've got in my ear or on my car
speakers and I'm still able to do other
other stuff all you have to do to get
started is go to audible.com Dr Mike or
text Dr Mike to the number 500 500.
remember though doctor is spelled out
and by signing up you're going to get a
free 30-day trial as an audible member
you get access to one credit a month
that can be used on any title from their
Premium Selection such as the latest
best sellers you also get access to the
audible plus catalog which has guided
meditations podcasts and so much more
the link is down below let's get back to
our interview with Dr off next we moved
on to how marketers and big Tech CEOs
have sold us this false notion of
maximally optimizing help moving many
from a fact-based health system to a
faith-based system because we
desperately want to believe in magic but
I'm a skeptic of biohacking so I ask in
the space where I function which is
primarily in social media anything that
has new tech involved Silicon Valley
money in it people get excited Elon Musk
tweets about it and it becomes a huge
story to the general public that they
think they found a shortcut to treating
some illness improving abilities
optimizing health and it could not be
further from the truth because in
medicine unless you're a clinician you
may not realize that changing one thing
will change three other things down the
line that you completely didn't expect
or completely negates whatever it is
that you tried to do in the first place
have you seen biohacking in the hospital
with your patients in media have you
spoke about that at all not really I
guess to me probably the best example
would be something like theranos you
know where here you have just this one
fingerprint prick of blood just that
would fill up a very tiny sort of micro
cuvette that'll that where you can do
200 or 300 tests which already was like
you know like otherworldly right I mean
because there's no way you're going to
be able to do 200 tests unless you
dilute those samples and every time you
dilute something you lose information
and Things become less reliable it never
made sense to me what was interesting is
when it first appeared right because it
was that's exactly right it was like you
know Silicon Valley big Tech she got she
you know Elizabeth Holmes got billions
and billions of dollars of evaluation
and got major players to in it to stand
up and be like George Schultz you know
at the very least you know at Mattis and
stuff and um it was just built on Sand
and it never made sense and and I
remember reading about science or nature
you know which are excellent scientific
journals that also bought into it so
it's like even the highest of what
should be skepticism was just you know
we wanted to believe so so we we've gone
from sort of you know science to
religion we moved from a fact-based
system to a belief system which is never
a good idea do you think it's excitement
over the potential progress that we
could be making that's leading us to
look the other way yes you want to
believe you want to believe where we can
be magical we believe we do believe in
magic as it turns out that's true um
some of the examples that I have written
down that I wanted to discuss is um
anything related to metabolism
um tracking has been created as if or
labeled as if it's the next great thing
the next answer for everything and what
the reality for me as a practicing
physician is more information is not
always better in fact it's confusing and
it makes it difficult to treat a patient
for example the Apple watch does a
fantastic job at tracing your heart rate
and telling you when you have a moment
of atrial fibrillation but when a
patient brings that in who's otherwise
healthy who's 20 years old and had two
seconds of afib I have no idea what to
do with it because the evidence has not
told me what to do with it have you ever
had a conversation with a patient with
some kind of tech issue like this no no
I mean I'm an ID guy so it's not the
effects of these guys you know that
hasn't that hasn't come up but you're
right I mean I think we like we want
that simple thing that single thing this
sort of you know this reductionist
thinking you know that one magical thing
that that we can point to so no that
hasn't happened I'm an older position so
so this is going to be much more of a
phenomenon time for you than me that
makes sense
um for me I see it as almost an
extension of uh your book uh for example
screening programs you know I follow the
guidance of the United States preventive
service task force when I look at what
screening programs I should be involved
in to me a screening test should be able
to spot an illness early in an
asymptomatic otherwise healthy person
and allow me to intervene meaningfully
and there's a lot of things where we
were doing early on your example being
Prime prostate cancer screening we would
check everyone's PSAs find all these
false positives or positives that were
related to BPH and not actually prostate
cancer that led to further extra testing
that wasn't necessary side effects from
this testing Downstream negative effects
but still to this day I have urologists
that are writing blogs that are actually
speaking down to the fact that family
physicians are not ordering PSAs as
regularly as we used to
um again it seems like it's with good
intention but then it creates all these
Downstream problems that we weren't
ready to face
your experience in medicine is vast
tell us how to stop doing and remaking
the same mistakes over and over again so
when you say my experience in medicine
is that's what you're really trying to
say in a nice way is that I'm old got it
no wisdom wisdom
no I mean that's a perfect example I'm
first of all the PSA wasn't designed for
that purpose it wasn't designed as a
cancer screening test
um and and so what was interesting to me
the analogy that I loved actually in the
writing this book was sort of this
Barnyard analogy of this sort of the
turtles the rabbits or the Birds
um a screening test is a value if if you
screen somebody who had you not screened
them and picked something up you they
would have died otherwise so that's it
so therefore that screening test
prolongs your life that's a good
screening so I think colonoscopy
reasonably prolongs your life and Pap
smears reasonably prolonged your life
but prostate cancer you know if you look
at people who who go through the sort of
standard you know get PSAs the PSA is
high get a biopsy if biopsy shows you
know worse something it's worrisome to
go through radiation therapy or surgical
therapy
um they there should be clear evidence
that people that go through that live
longer than people who don't go through
any of that and there isn't which means
that the people who are going through
that are doing a lot of suffering in
terms of you know either radiation
therapy or surgery or both and and um
that's what was really striking to me so
so it's like the what you want is you
want you're really trying to what you
really care about is you care about the
sort of the rabbit so you so you open up
the Barn Door the turtle is is not going
to get out while you open that burner
because he's so slow so that's like the
cancer that you die with and not from
and a large percentage of people in
their 80s die with prostate cancer but
not from it meaning when you do look at
their prostate they have obvious
cancerous lesions
um and then there's the bird that it
doesn't matter you know whether you you
try and close the door quickly you're
going the bird flies out anyway that's
the cancer you're going to die from no
matter what you do so it's the rabbits
you're trying to like here's the rabbit
coming you close the door in time and
you save your life but mostly prostate
cancer is a lot of turtles and birds so
it's not like people don't die of
prostate cancer they do the question is
where's the odds that by the time you've
made that diagnosis you're already past
the point where you're going to save
their life I mean I watched my father go
through this and go through you know
radiation and surgery ultimately for his
cancer and um you know he suffered a lot
not lastly we said continent it was
difficult for him and I just don't think
they did anything to prolong his life
they just but I said once you're
diagnosed with cancer you know people
now have this notion please get this out
of me you know you can't just say look
you're probably going to die with it not
from it so don't worry about it because
people are worried about it so it's hard
what's your take uh on Specialists
pushing back on some of these arguments
and saying well we've updated the way
that we treat these patients we've
instituted watchful waiting rechecking
numbers not necessarily jumping to
biopsies perhaps other types of scanning
and imaging do you think that warrants
further testing before continuing the
recommendation of screening everybody
well I think that's happening
my sense but I like you go with this
sort of preventive task force
recommendations because I think they're
the most informed but they've moved away
from this sort of you know the sort of
constant you know PSA testing and then
biopsy they've slowly moved away from
that which I really like I think that's
bold but but get people to understand
that is the hard part I mean that's I
mean I'm a pediatric infection disease
specialist so I don't have to worry
about trying to convince people not to
get PSAs or biopsies but but I but I did
I mean I got I had very high PSAs and
they want to do biopsies and the
biopsies were questionable it's like I
finally just said forget it let this let
me die of prostate cancer if I'm going
to die prostate cancer and leaving this
was years ago so prostate cancer hasn't
gotten me and I suspect it never will I
maybe I'll die with prostate cancer but
I just I realize there's more and more I
read and it was in the writing this book
that was all happening I just thought
this is ridiculous why are we doing this
and I remember going to the urologist
who was recommending all this and saying
I just can't see evidence for why we're
doing this how it helps me and he was
unconvincing and and he but he was
credit he let me sort of do it my way
what's interesting is I keep running
into the same issue in speaking with you
because I feel like you're almost like a
primary care doctor in the sense of the
issues you bring up in your writing
these are all of the same issues I run
into in my practice whether it's
antipyretics antibiotics the screening
programs all of these problems start in
the primary care visit Elise with me and
one of those issues is supplementation
and the promising of miracle cures we
will fix what ails you if you don't eat
a healthy diet your insurance pill is
the multivitamin
that is probably as a young Doctor Who's
on the internet making a lot of content
that I speak down upon in terms of
saying that you don't need these things
I get the biggest pushback on vitamin D
is something you've written about in
your book something I frequently
frequently push back on Specialists on I
have dermatologists that put my patients
uh with a Target goal of 70 for their
vitamin D levels and I'm like where is
the evidence for what you're doing or
um even the Endocrinology societies not
pushing back hard on these other
specialties
what do we do about sort of fighting
back against the misinformation that
supplements are the cure-all they are
what's missing in order to keep us
healthy what do we do from for the
general public here um it's the
Zeitgeist I mean it is just the way
things are right now so you're pushing
up against this tremendous wave of our
culture that wants this magic pill and
and we've convinced people that that and
it's easy to convince them because
because I think if you pull people most
people will not think that they eat
particularly healthy diets I had a pizza
last night for dinner
um and and a sub for lunch today
um and so you know people say like their
bodies are temples you know and they
that's how they worship them well mine's
more like like you know this sort of
garbage dump where raccoons kind of like
hang out and forage but that's one of me
but but honesty I love the honesty no we
need more of that so
um it's easy then for people to say look
if you don't happen to eat a
particularly healthy diet here's this
pill that will make it so that you know
you'll get everything that you need but
the fact the matter is you get at pretty
much everything you need in Foods
independent whether or not you eat what
is considered a healthy diet or not for
the most part and and you're right the
vitamin D story was really interesting
to me because you're right I mean it's
not I mean I'm in the world of pediatric
effects diseases this doesn't come up a
lot but it was really surprise I went
into this by the book uh this book was
uh or one of the books was um Do You
Believe in Magic the sense and nonsense
of alternative medicine in addition to
Overkill that was the sort of skeptical
look at at these therapies and I kept
wanting to find something you know that
showed that say supplements work because
otherwise just come off as a complete
naysayer and I had a lot of trouble
finding that
um evidence for that I mean because
vitamin D has been argued for a cure-all
for a preventive for everything uh you
know cancer or Strokes heart attacks I
mean this is even false medicine I don't
know where they that's right even Falls
that's right that's right so there were
some recommendations early on that were
shocking to me and skin Health
everything but no one wanted to believe
that taking vitamins can actually really
lead to more harm and I think your book
illuminates both of those points can you
tell us where taking supplements outside
of taking supplements that have you know
arsenic or some other toxic elements to
them but vitamins on their own can be
harmful tell us about that well it's it
obviously vitamins are critical Vita
life I mean you need vitamins or or
substances which your body needs but
cannot make on its own you need vitamins
this is that's not the issue the issue
is how best to get them and the answer
is the best way to get them is from food
you I give credit to the nutritional
supplement companies for being able to
sell what they they sell as natural
because it's not natural that's not how
your body is meant to take in vitamins
in a compressed pill that has a large
quantity of vitamin that is not
associated with the other phytochemicals
that are typically found in vegetables
and fruits and and when you do it that
way you're not preventing it and
presenting it in natural way you're
presenting it in an unnatural way which
can then have consequences and that's
what we found out now the vitamin C can
have consequences when taking large
quantities so can vitamin D Etc vitamin
E I mean so
um it surprises me they don't have black
box warnings on them and they would have
black box warnings on it for these sort
of multivitamins or or the uh sort of
high level of vitamins that people take
if the FDA was able to regulate them but
you know that dietary supplement health
and Education Act pushed back against
the FDA on this and so the FDA doesn't
really regulate them the way they should
so people don't know and and that's what
was also interesting to me is just
you're here you talk about going up
against the Zeitgeist of the current
culture of the desire to take a pill but
go up against you know these these
nutritional supplement companies I mean
they have an enormous amount of money
and influence and you know and I just
feel so sorry for the patient who's
caught up in all this
because I think people push towards the
supplement space for two reasons one
they think it's natural which is
incorrect as you put right now and the
second is that they believe against
Pharma companies they have a negative
biased view of Pharma companies which is
important I think we need to take a
skeptical look about how Pharma
companies do their testing their
approvals their pricing especially but
the reality of Pharma companies getting
rich off of selling us certain
medications and the point you brought up
which I think is an understated Point uh
that Pharma companies love creating
drugs that patients would take for years
upon years and daily as opposed to
finding cures as opposed to finding the
new antibiotic is probably the worst
form of how Pharma functions but these
nutritional supplement companies that
pawn off their supplements As Natural
are also billion dollar entities just
like the Pharma companies except with no
regulation like they're both billionaire
companies one is forced to prove that
they're uh their medications work or
what their side effects can be and one
has free reign to do whatever they want
and yet the public doesn't scrutinize
the nutritional companies at all it's
amazing I mean I'm on the FDA vaccine
advisory committee right so we sit down
and we did say in December 10th or 17th
to go over Pfizer's vaccine and then
modernist vaccine those were 40 000
person studies 30 000 per studies you
know where you get a 200 pages of of
material to read before you go through
the meeting where you look at every
piece of data in terms of safety and
efficacy and then and only then do you
make sort of a recommendation to move
forward on those vaccines and the
nutritional supplement companies just
make it up I mean what's on the label
doesn't necessarily have to be what's in
the bottle and people feel much more
comfortable with that than they do with
this this highly regulated highly
supervised and scrutinized process it is
remarkable I give credit to these
companies for having sold us a bill of
goods and I also give credit to Mother
Nature I don't know who her through her
public relations team is but I want to
hire that that group because she has
been trying to kill us ever since we
crawled out of the ocean on the land I
mean people say we'll go so as far as to
say they want to have like a natural
covet infection as you know because
that's better than getting a vaccine
look in some ways like a natural fever
is better than blocking a fever so I
kind of see where that started but then
there's like this element of concept
creep which Jonathan height talks about
so well where you know natural can be
better it doesn't mean that it's always
better and uh you know certain toxins
are natural it doesn't mean that we
should be taking them in Dr offit sits
on the FDA vaccine advisory committee
which means he advises the FDA on which
vaccines to approve or not approve which
is why I found it so interesting to
learn how critical he is of both the
Biden and Trump administration's
politicization of Health Guidance Do you
think that a part of this is uh the loss
of trust in medical institutions oh
certainly absolutely and I think that
wasn't always true I I mean I was a
child of the 50s
um I'll give you a perfect example when
when uh when Jonas off made his polio
vaccine
um he he took the virus grew it up in in
cells in the laboratory purified it
killed it with the chemical
formaldehydes was a whole killed viral
vaccine
um and then five companies step forward
to make it one of them made it badly
cutter Laboratories of Berkeley
California failed to fully inactivate
the polio virus that was in their
vaccine it's a consequence 120 000
children primarily in the west and
southwest were inoculated with live
fully virulent fully dangerous
poliovirus 40 000 developed short-lived
polio many temporary paralysis 164 were
permanently paralyzed for the rest of
their life and 10 were killed I think it
was the single worst biological disaster
in this country's history and in no
sense shook faith in the polio vaccine
people generally believe the companies
were trying to do their best if you
looked at the exit interviews from all
the original uh those early uh lawsuits
against Qatar
um you would see that that the the
people who were sitting on those roots
saw what this was which was a scale up
incident that we just hadn't figured out
how to mass produce That vaccine yet and
and and wanted to find cutter not guilty
because not you know not responsible
amazingly enough
um but but and because they trusted the
companies they trusted the government
they trusted the medical community and
and something changed I think in the 60s
and 70s something changed I mean it
became much more cynical much more
litigious sort of what I call kind of
the post-warter gay phenomenon you know
where we saw that there were sort of
evil forces lurking behind the curtains
you know whether it's Pentagon papers or
the Nixon tapes when there was a loss of
trust yeah do you think the CDC or the
FDA can be functioning in a more
effective way when it comes to
communication with the general public
whether it's about vaccines or vitamin
supplements because it feels like
there's somehow a gap the FDA makes
statements you have medical experts go
on Good Morning America Etc but yet
there the efficacy isn't there it's
almost like how we talk about you know
some of the things you mentioned in your
book we do them just to do them with no
evidence behind them if the FD the a
issues a press release and no one reads
it and it changes no one's mind
shouldn't we be looking at other ways of
communicating with the general public
yes I think there has been during covet
especially there has been a real loss of
trust in the public health agents
agencies and public health officials I
think and some level deservedly so I
think that if you look
um at what happened in the previous
administration and president Trump's
Administration what you saw was you saw
that the administration could actually
arm twist the FDA arm twist them into
approving through emergency use
authorization hydroxychloroquine an
anti-malarial drug that had never been
shown to work to either treat or prevent
covid and they approve that I mean they
three months later they took away the
approval when the it was shown not to
work and shown to have a heart
arrhythmias which could be fatal but
that really shook people's confidence I
mean so much so that that before the the
vaccine was released um in December
um people were so worried about what the
Trump Administration would do was that
States didn't trust the FDA or the FDA
vaccine advisor committee and formed
their own advisory committees that's how
bad it was also I do think now for
example if fantasies could come true I
would like to do what communicate covid
the way we communicated the swine flu
pandemic in 2009 I mean so here was a
pandemic that came into this country
killed about 12 000 people it was a
worldwide pandemic with with this novel
uh strain of influenza virus about two
percent of the worldwide deaths occurred
in this country about a little more than
12 000 people died of that virus in this
country
um every day every other day there was
Richard besser head of the CDC
telling you where things are and why
should it have been him because all the
the data you cared about all the
epidemiological data came from the CDC
didn't come from NIH didn't come from
the administration came from the CDC
also where is the CDC it's in Atlanta so
he was oh he's giving his conferences
from Atlanta now what you see is you see
these proclamations coming out of
Washington and and therefore they are
subject to political influence I mean
fantasies could come true I would like
to see Dr Rachelle olinski do all the
talking out of her her perch in Atlanta
because that's where that's really all
that the the uh the stuff's coming and
it's like radio silence I mean you don't
hear anything and and and what bester
understood was that the media were the
voices of the people those were the
questions of the people that the people
had to answer and he answered them
patiently every other day it was great
and we have gotten away from that and
it's hard I mean I'm only as as a voting
member of the FDA vaccine advisor it's
hard to watch some of these things I
mean it's not just the Trump
Administration when President Biden
stood up on August 8 18th and said as of
September 20th we are going to have a
booster dose of covet vaccine for
everybody over 16. where did that come
from I actually called a senior official
at the White House and said where is
this coming from where the data that
drives that recommendation and in fact
we kept pushing back on that
recommendation until Omicron hit and
then sort of the floodgates open for
booster dosing and I'm still a little
lost about for whom this is a two dose
vaccine for whom it's a three dose
vaccine for whom it's a four dose
vaccine and where boosters fit into any
of this honestly if you ask 10 Americans
what does it mean to be fully vaccinated
you'd probably get 10 different answers
because it's that confusing and I blame
us for that I do and that's not it
that's not a general American issue
that's a doctor issue patients ask me
the same and depending on their age I
make like a clarification statement but
the reality is we don't know you know
nature had a good publication showing a
lot of efficacy for a second booster for
those over the age of 60. but
it matters that Nuance matters and I
feel like Nuance is lost especially on
social media I don't know how active you
are on Twitter and other sources in
terms of reading what others are saying
but the second you have disagreement
even amongst educational sources whether
it's someone from Hopkins talking to
someone from Stanford if there is even a
small amount of disagreement there's a
lot of labeling that occurs where if you
don't fully stand with the FDA or CDC if
you're a critique will even one bit it
somehow means you're taking an anti-vax
stance or furthering the anti-vax agenda
is that type of labeling necessary is it
uh against what we're trying to achieve
in your eyes of course I mean I think
it's SNL Saturday Night Live had sort of
a a comedy Skittle now where you've had
a group of sort of maybe three couples
sitting around a table in New York and
one of them started started to say you
know questioning whether or not you
really needed to mask in a particular
situation and then that person was
vaporized you know it was like right you
can't question it all right now things
are so confusing I'm not sure what
exactly the story is I you we the
Committee FDA vaccine advisor committee
are going to be meeting the end of June
to pick strains for what I think they
want to have as a yearly or at least
every sort of late fall early winter
booster dose and I don't understand the
thinking there I don't I'm on the
committee and I'm supposed to be picking
strains and the way I see this why do we
get a yearly flu vaccine we get a yearly
flu vaccine because even if you've been
vaccinated or or infected the year
before you're still at risk for serious
disease for the most part protection
against serious disease holds up with
this vaccine I do think that for some
this is truly a three dose vaccine I do
that that that that third dose when
given four to six months later increases
your frequency of memory b t so that you
are better protected against seriously
and that's the immune component
associated with protection against
serious disease people over 65 people
who have comorbidities I still can't
quite fathom the clear evidence that a
healthy less than 50 year old really
benefits from a third dose in terms of
protection against serious illness which
is the goal unless that's not the goal
unless the goal is preventing mild
illness in which case we're going to
have to keep boosting because
neutralizing antibodies always fade at
some level three to six months after a
vaccination so is that the goal in which
case we're always going to be boosting
which is great news for for uh companies
I'm just not sure it's necessarily good
news for us is is there any truth
um to the fact that if we decrease the
likelihood of developing mild infections
that we decrease uh new strains from
coming about well first of all good luck
with that I mean this is a short
incubation period disease you know the
viremia or virus spread in the
bloodstream is not an important part of
the disease process for these kinds of
short incubation period diseases the
goal is to prevent the only reasonable
goal the only achievable goal is to
prevent really moderate to severe them
so now I was fortunate enough to be part
of a team at Children's Hospital
Philadelphia that created the strains
that became the rotavirus vaccine Road
attack that was a 26-year effort I am
the co-inventor of the rotor virus
vaccine that is a mucosal infection like
SARS cov2 meaning short incubation
period infects a mucosal surface when
you have short incubation periods you
are not going to be able to protect for
any length of time against mild or
asymptomatic infection I mean we have
eliminated essentially with our vaccine
uh hospitalizations in babies from
rotavirus we've done that but the virus
still circulates in the community that's
going to be true here too we're not
going to prevent mild disease and so I
think what people worry about now was if
it's true if I get mild disease can I
still get long coveted and you know I
don't want to get a mild disease and and
even people on the uh the CDC Advisory
Committee just last week said we we have
to have a better vaccine against
milesies well if you want a better
vaccine against mild disease figure out
a way to lengthen the incubation period
because otherwise you're going to have
trouble doing that it's just it's hard
to watch I think coming off this Zero
Tolerance strategy for covet we're going
to have to realize mild disease is going
to be part of this for the rest of our
lives I mean for this virus is going to
circulate for decades and it's going to
continue to cause mild illness and and
even if the whole entire world were
vaccinated that would still be true and
I don't think people quite understand
that State Medical boards exist to keep
doctors ethically and legally in check
yet too often doctors get away with
placing profits over patients
considering Dr offit is well versed in
the art of the snake oil salesman I
asked him do you think Medical Board
should be taking a more proactive stance
here in sort of disciplinary action-wise
yes I do and they don't I mean I'm right
now I'm in Avalon New Jersey three
blocks from now from here there's an IV
vitamin treatment center it's actually
right next to a bar and one of the ways
that they promote themselves is to say
it kind of detox yourself after the
after drinking too much yeah I mean I
think the the I think as generally
licensing agencies ethics boards are
terrible we are terrible as Physicians
about policing ourselves terrible and so
who pleases us you know in theory
lawyers pleases but you know there they
don't really know so much for bad care
as much as they do for bad outcomes
which are always going to be true so
that's not an effective way to please us
no I think you're exactly right or
people who who recommend against
vaccines or you know it but it and it's
it's it's all marketing right I mean I
think some Physicians realize there is
this is that they can with a boutique
practice you can look like you care
you're buying into the Zeitgeist here
are these magic pills that will make you
healthier and better and have better sex
and thicker hair or whatever it is that
they're promoting and it's hard to watch
and we are terrible at uh
at really regulating ourselves here and
that's why everybody gets away with it
yeah like I thought that by starting my
YouTube channel reaching millions of
people I mean monthly we get 70 80
million viewers on our YouTube channel
and I thought if I could talk about why
there's no evidence for some of these
things or why I don't believe they work
and explain the science behind it people
would listen and while some people do
the frequent pushback I get is you're a
young doctor you didn't go to an Ivy
League school you don't understand the
science that this person is talking
about but when I've even been approached
by these companies to promote their
product I would love to promote a
product that cures like some of the
illnesses that they talk about because I
deal with them in my practice and I see
how much they hurt my patients I would
love to have a pill to say oh you have
irritable bowel syndrome that destroys
your life here is a probiotic to solve
it it just doesn't exist and when the
companies come to me they flood me with
10 000 pages of research and when I
really spend the hours looking at the
research they don't even prove that
their probiotic pill Works they prove
that their probiotic pill survives in
the acidic environment in the in the
stomach and somehow that that means it
works but the reality is they make you
look at the cool stuff on one hand but
don't really substantiate it with
anything else and I feel almost
powerless to attack it because you can't
attack something like you said in the
beginning of this interview that you
can't say with definite proof does not
work I can't say with 100 Proof those
probiotics don't work I could say
there's no evidence that they work how
do we attack this industry more
effectively I think at the very least we
have to show that there are downsides
that that anything that has a positive
effect can have a negative effect and
that you can see now with because I
think people don't know that people
don't know that for example if you take
these high quantities of vitamin C that
you increase your risk of kidney stones
for example and that that can be serious
uh that's just one one of many examples
and I think people don't this Con this
this industry has gotten away with this
notion this false notion that it's all
positive and nothing bad can happen
that's never true in medicine if there's
if something doesn't have a negative
effect it probably never had a positive
effect and I just think we need to pull
the curtain back because I do think that
works at some level when people see some
of the um nefarious nature of the way
that this all works but but I would like
to say one thing in case we're going to
end soon is I am really happy there are
people like you out there I mean young
people who are skeptical as Physicians
that really are looking behind the
curtain here it is heartening to me to
know that you're out there thank you for
being out there well honestly inspired
by you and your skepticism because I
always feel in medicine you need to have
a very strong balance between being a
healthy skeptic and not disbelieving any
new innovation and Technology because
it's very easy to fall into that trap
where anything new is bad and we don't
want to go that route and at the same
time uh to say anything revolutionary
must remove everything that we've done
that's time tested and proved and proven
so to me I actually just did an
interview for Medscape the other day day
about the differences between older
Physicians and younger Physicians and
the answer wasn't one or the other I
don't prefer one or the other in fact
it's the collaborative approach of the
two let's learn what worked over the
years let's take the younger approach
how we can make technology work with us
instead of against us but not sell out
to these hedge fund companies that want
to run medicine in a way that you know
makes the the checkbook get a little
thinner get the wallet thinner as
opposed to our waste thinner
um
to me that's the most disheartening
thing I think that medicine is becoming
to be a hedge fund in the business world
and that happens even in the
telemedicine front
um you'll see like we have to go virtual
uh for the first few months of covid
because our office shut down and I saw
how ineffective this was in so many of
my patients cases you know good luck
treating or figuring out abdominal pain
through a virtual exam virtually
worthless I would say
um there but there were some utility to
it and now what I see online is all
these companies popping up do a virtual
visit five minutes with our doctor will
give you Viagra will give you
antibiotics we'll give you Propecia will
make your hair grow thicker with no
checking to see is this patient having
erectile dysfunction because of severe
diabetes is this patient having a fungal
infection on their scalp and that's why
they're losing hair and all of these
things are sort of corrupting medicine
and I want to be the one pressing the
brakes and saying let's be good
marketers and see see what marketers do
well but push the evidence-based
approach with the marketing spin on it
and that's sort of an optimistic maybe
unrealistic goal that I've had with my
YouTube channel I don't know what your
take on that would be no I think that's
absolutely great I congratulations I
think I think it's a skepticism is
healthy cynicism isn't and so you know
be open-minded to the data to the fact
that there may be data that contradicts
something you believe is true have
believed it was true but don't be so
cynical that you don't believe clear
compelling reproducible data frequently
patients and friends will claim that
they've done the research which usually
means they did a quick Google search or
read a Facebook thread with everyone
these days considering themselves some
sort of expert I had to ask him in your
book bad advice you talked about how you
shouldn't take for the average person
shouldn't take advice from politicians
celebrities activists who should they
take advice from well you know it's it's
the experts I mean it's you know we
don't like that term this now and the
21st century you know trust me I'm an
expert that's not exactly something it
sells um but that is true you know when
people say to me um you know I've done
my research on the chickenpox vaccine
and I've decided not to get it but what
do they really mean by do their research
what they really mean is they've read
people's opinions about the vaccine on
the internet I mean if they really want
to do their research on the chickenpox
vaccine what they should do is they
should read the roughly 300 papers that
have been published on the vaccine which
would require some expertise in virology
Immunology epidemiology Etc most people
don't have that expertise frankly most
doctors don't have that expertise so
what do they do they they rely on Expert
advisory bodies like you know FDA
advisory committees and CDC Advisory
committees that at least collectively
have read those papers collectively have
an expertise to evaluate those those
papers and then collectively make a
decision about whether the vaccine is a
value but but you know that people just
don't do that and you can't it's
dismissive these days to say anything
like you know you really should rely on
you know informed opinion Based on data
doesn't work because people believe they
can be just as informed by you know
Googling the word Chickenpox vaccine as
anybody else which isn't true and and I
just you know so so trying to explain
that to people it's hard I mean it is I
think I I share some empathy for the uh
average member of the public because we
say to look to the CDC the FDA for
guidance and you sit on the uh acip
committee and yet you're saying that the
FDA is pushing some things along that
you just frankly don't agree with and
it's confusing to you how it's gotten
well I said on the FDA committee
actually I used to be on these these if
I've been on both committees you're
right and I think what happens is it's
not the Committees that are the problem
it's when the the administration
bypasses the committee when President
Biden stood up in in August of last year
and said we're going to offer booster
doses for everybody he bypassed the FDA
and bypassed the CDC that's that's bad
that's a bad thing to do so we as
medical experts should keep
church and state separate in the sense
of church being science and state being
government because it's very clear how
that undue influence can not only
directly harm those institutions but
also hurt the public trust yes I agree
natural remedies aren't all bad in fact
here I've compiled a list of 10 natural
remedies that actually work click here
to check that out and as always stay
happy and healthy I'll see you in the
natural remedies video